i'm a head of openpilot uh my
presentation will be uh will be about
openpilot
um so the responsibility of the
openpilot team is basically all the code
that lives on your device so your
command2 or your command3
from the research team we get this nice
blob of weights from the neural nets and
then it's our job to run this as stable
as possible
and to interface with a whole bunch of
cars
and to be this reliable we're basically
trying to build this the most stable
robotics platform that's possible
so um in my presentation
um i'll be going over some open pilot
features uh i'll be taking you
on like a history tour
um but i'll start off with this uh
solving self-driving cars is
a software problem only
um
some people think this is what a
self-driving car looks like it's a
a car filled with computers because
otherwise yeah you can never build a
self-driving car
of course we don't think this is true
if you would ask someone at a
traditional self-driving car company
what you would need and they would say
you need a lot of cameras you need a
lidar of course you need a lighter i
need a radar you need imus a gyroscope
an accelerometer a gps and definitely a
trend full of computers
um
well
everyone knows that lighter is a scam so
we can immediately cross that off the
list so people use this to make their hd
maps and then localize themselves in the
in the hd map to do their planning on
um yeah that doesn't scale so
definitely no lighter
i can also say confidently that a trunk
full of computers is not going to be
necessary um we can run open pipe very
comfortably on the comma 2 and the comma
3 is even better
um so yeah and it's not a problem of
compute i'll i'll get to that later
definitely not cpu
um
then we can also cross radar off the
list i've been we've been using radar
for quite a while
um i looked a little into the data that
the radar gives us but the data is
actually pretty shitty
you get this like one line you get all
these false positives it's really hard
to tell apart like a stationary car or
like a manhole cover
um so we very quickly switch to a system
where we only use vision
to tell if a car is there or not and
then we still use the radar to um to
give us a speed because the the radar
gives us a doppler shift uh which is an
instant measurement of the speed which
is very nice but we're also moving away
from this and trusting the model to give
us the relative velocity of the car
and tesla is doing this now as well so
this jose
this is very very possible
um and i
would say an imu and a gps are kind of
optional for the driving part over time
our models have become very good at
estimating the motion that the car is
going through will tell us the
rotational velocities and the
accelerations and the velocities
and the gps of course you can drive
through the tunnels without a gps it's
very possible to drive
um but yeah for ground trooping those
things are very nice so we definitely
put those on
and then the most important part is the
cameras uh if you have some very good
cameras which the comments three has
this should be all you need this is what
a human drives with their eyes so
good cameras are very important and the
cameras on the commentary are really
amazing
i worked quite a bit with them already
george talked about 120 db of dynamic
range
uh they do hdr they do full four
exposures at the same time so you have
four exposures
and each successive exposure has a 16x
slow shorter exposure time
so in this way you can see very dark but
very bright areas at the same time
um
so yeah this is kind of what
represents open pilot uh over time
um we've been running on the on the lay
code or the oneplus 3 and basically
openpipe has always filled all the
available cpu space
but it was always fine like if we wanted
to try to ship a new feature we would
free up some cpu we would rewrite
something
um
[Music]
in c plus plus make it faster and then
in the end we always have the cpu
available to the right a feature we want
um so yeah we've been running on 2016
era smartphone for quite a while
uh and actually we don't plug the cpu a
couple times just for thermal
performance because the cooling is
really terrible but still we're only
using like 65 percent of this cpu i mean
the gpu is a different question but cpu
there's definitely plenty of
um so yeah now i'm going to take you on
a tour of open pile features some some
nice milestones basically from version
0.1 to the upcoming release version
0.8.7
this is between 2016 and 2021.
um this is basically
release this is the acura ilex with
still the computer in the back
uh and the joystick to engage and
disengage this is what
uh george took the bloomberg reporter on
to uh to vegas
so this is kind of the shape of open
pilot uh you can see the the open pile
of ui in the bottom left um we still
have that debug ui around so happy to
see that that code still exists
um and then it was time for the
basically the initial open source
release which ran on the the karma neo
it's like this whole diy
to 3d print a bunch
and this is also where the neon green
color came from we got a bunch of 3d
printers and when you buy the 3d printer
it comes with
a little bit of free filament in the
most hideous color you can imagine of
course
so that's why a bunch of our stuff was
neon green
i think we still have
quite a few spools of that left
um this is what the ui looked like um
back then so
very engineery hackery with all the
green boxes all the lines
but over time like a lot nicer as
well um and i want to talk about a
feature in 0.3.7 about model predictive
control um i mean the feature itself is
nice but this was my my first feature i
shipped as an intern
after i joined comma
um this basically made the controls way
more smooth instead of some like
it turned it into an optimization
problem so you put in like the position
of the leaf car and the velocities of
the leaf car and you try to optimize the
brake and the gas and the steering to
get the most smooth maneuvers possible
and a lot of this code is still around
which is very nice
harold made some tweaks to it in the
meantime but the the basic stuff is
still around so
it was um it was pretty cool to see that
a comma when you write a feature and
then in in a few months you have this
running i mean at the time at a few
hundred users but now it's like
thousands of users uh that run your code
another feature i worked on as an intern
was for question warning
um this is when i kind of realized that
the power of all the data that comma has
uh so
when you
at the time this wasn't no machine
learning but i used the model outputs
to see what the current front was doing
and then i made some rules to come up
with uh when to show the four question
one then i could use all the data to see
what if this had any false positives to
tweak the algorithm and this is yeah
this really showed the power of the data
and this is probably something the oems
can't even do
they have to go to a test track and some
testing
um
0.4.4 was the big flipping i thought it
was pretty funny uh so when we designed
the original eon
we actually put the selfie camera on the
right side of the device uh which turned
out to be a mistake um when we wanted to
start gathering uh driver monitoring
footage uh we want to put the camera on
the left so we just flipped everything
around
um lucky the eon case was symmetrical so
uh with a hex screwdriver you could take
it apart flip the mount around and then
put it back in your car and chris even
made a nice video about that three years
ago
[Music]
so this is the the first step towards
driver monitoring which is very
important
um when i was going through the release
notes i also noticed this pretty funny
thing and version 0.4.6 which fix all
memory leaks
i don't think that was actually true
but it was very optimistic at least
in version 0.4.7 we shipped the first
model with our improved brand choosing
stack
um
so before we just we we tried to recover
the path that the car took we used
mostly as the gyroscope for this and
then
all gyroscopes have a bias which we
didn't remove properly
so before this point all the models had
like this bias that would point you to
slightly towards the right if you looked
in the distance the model would always
do this
uh so we had this this fixed offset of
one and a half degrees which we always
subtracted before we sent the angle to
the steering controller
but after this was finally gone so just
close cool to mention
[Music]
then in version 0.5.0 we shipped right
for monitoring i'm sure wishing is going
to talk a lot more about the driver
monitoring but yeah as opposed to
getting better and better uh like in the
first version we had just this bar that
took six minutes to come down and he had
to touch the wheel
um i mean six minutes now in hindsight
is a very long time
but overpaid messed up so so often that
you felt very proud if you actually hit
the six minute mark and you're always
paying attention
but then as opposed got better it made
less mistakes and then it become very
important to make sure that the driver
is paying attention um and yeah you can
you can just make the wheel touch time
shorter but at some some point that just
becomes too annoying
so we actually want to make sure that
the user is paying attention so we look
at their face and see if they're looking
at their wrist
then in version 0.5.8 we open source
vision d
um we always joke that we were probably
one of the first companies to actually
ship a neural net on the edge on like a
device in in the field uh back at the in
the day we wrote our own opencl kernels
to do all the neural net stuff uh but at
some point we shipped to the smp which
is a qualcomm library to do it as well
and they have all these these nice uh
opencl kernels i reverse engineered
their their library once and they're
they're super tweaked for what the the
snapdragon can do so they're super good
uh so we should switch to s p
um and then so we just decided to open
source vision d uh and at that point all
the code in in open file was open source
which is a pretty cool milestone
um then in version 0.7.7
we actually started driving on the
localizer so to speak um so all cars of
course are different uh all the tires
have different grip on the road and this
can depend on like how wet the road is
how the temperature
and there's the steering it's like the
manufacture system some end-to-end ratio
usually but this is not true for all
driving
so we try for each car
we try to estimate the vehicle
and with like 130 car support this is
very important because you can't be
measuring this for every car
uh so we actually uh estimate this
offline we look at how the car drives we
look at the steering angle the speed
and then we predict how we think the car
should drive and then we could tweak uh
the vehicle parameters a bit so it
matches our expectation
and this is very important for things
like bank roads so if the road is a
little slope to the left or right
then you would start hugging but this
actually takes care of that it sees that
the the car is not driving as expected
and then compensates for it
uh in version
0.8.0 we shipped the first full 3d
driving model
that would not only output lanes and
paths and xy but also in z
um and this was mostly useful
for the
the discussions the open pi team had
with research
we would look at like a replay and they
would say now this model is
overestimating the turn um but you have
to be very careful because of projection
errors that if the road would slope up
or down a little bit it would completely
throw off how the lines looked and the
research team always said no no it's not
overestimating it's just
it's just a projection and then well
turned out usually in a lot of cases we
were right and this is the one of the
bugs that harold was talking about with
the yellow lane lines at
night and then in version 0 8.3 we
shipped the first end-to-end lateral
model uh which is yeah a big very big
step which is something that the
research team has been working on for a
very long time
and i'm very excited to see what the
future of this will look like
and then in the same release we also
switched to a ui and qt we had this
massive code base in react native
although the ui was was an android apk
and then with uh at the time we're
already working on the on the comma
three as well um so yeah we uh we moved
the whole ui to qt it's super responsive
now um and it's all it lives in the same
open pilot code base so we didn't have
to rewrite all the messaging stuff
in uh january 2020 we also made a very
important change on how openpod is
developed so openpilot used to be
developed in a cathedral style open
source
which means all the development happens
behind the scenes and then when there's
a release you get this dump on get up
with all the source uh but of course you
want to get contributions from the
community so people still make prs for
things like car support i just kind of
became like a pain to emerge
because like they could basic the public
code base was already behind people
couldn't see what we're working on
we started running all the ci behind the
scenes but then we couldn't run the pr's
on the ci uh so in january 2020 we just
decided to develop everything at open
source uh by the time we also didn't
need to testing cars anymore so
we could be pretty certain that if uh if
rci passed that if the code probably
wasn't broken
so if people start running that on their
device it wasn't such a big deal
uh so this was our old monorepo it was
called one everything was in one repo
um
yeah and then this grew for like the
three years that we used it uh but now
everything is done in the open pilot
repo and you can see this in the in the
graph the number of commits went up
significantly
and now all the all the developments
done in the public uh no no secret stuff
even the the common three stuff has been
developed in the open some people know
this but
yeah
so yeah i think this uh this shows us
very nicely how far we've come from
version 0.1 to version
0.8.7
um sometimes progress feels slow but
it's always good to take a step back and
see how far we've come and i think this
is very promising for what the future
will show us
if we can get this much out of the 2016
our smartphone i think that proves our
point that this is just a software
problem and if we just keep chipping
away at the software it's just gonna
keep getting better and better
so um what's next um
i think the most important part is
stability
um it's definitely a few features that
still need to be developed but yeah
stability is very important so we're
flirting one hours or 1000 hours between
failures so it means unplanned
disengagement so this can be anything
from a hard reboot which is very rare
now
um but also like communication error
between processes so if you don't meet
the real-time deadline
or other unexpected like planner
failures or model failures
of course we're going to start to keep
supporting more and more cars
and the open plan team is also going to
prepare running larger models it's
mostly a bandwidth problem with the gpu
so just by writing the
all the processing stages of the video
so it's like all the debayering um
all the all the conversions we do
just make sure that all runs on the c on
the gpu stays on the gpu
do efficient messaging so yeah
and of course we're going to talk about
navigation but i'm going to talk more
about that later
uh i also want to usually thank the
community who also make especially the
old 130 cars we support possible
uh you can see this is just
past months we had over 200 pull request
merged which is uh pretty cool i think a
while back on hacker news someone made a
tool to see how fast vrs were merged um
and it's also cool to see how quickly we
were processing all these pr's with
quite a small team
um yeah this this small team
um
forces us into certain things like not
writing a lot of code but these are
usually good things like we see this in
research too it's like yeah we're not
hiring a cone guy
we're a small team so we have to we have
to make sure that
we have as much leverage as possible so
this end-to-end approach makes a lot of
sense
um and if you have a lot of people
you're tricked into these approaches
that don't scale well and even with all
those people still will never work
uh so i think this is true for the
number of lines of code as well if you
you can do a lot with not a lot of code
um so yeah like the sudo project it's
like over two hundred thousand lines of
code
um yeah with open pi we're trying to
keep the number of lines of code below
100 000 and so far we've
succeeded
now we can also plot this over time
um so yeah we're you can see uh version
0.5.8 there's a big increase when we
open source vision d on camera d uh and
then in version 0.7.7 we started to get
awfully close to the 100 000 line limit
so we did a big cleanup started to
remove all unnecessary code
and that was comfortably
down to 60 000 again
um and this is still an amount of code
that one person can keep in their head
uh i know what all the moving parts are
and just
makes a lot easier to develop on open as
well
but as you can see the number of cars
that support it keeps going up um and
robin mentioned this as well nicely that
we only need 45 lines of code for each
supported car just because we have very
nice car abstraction links
um i also want to talk briefly about the
hardware that's needed to run open file
uh
so in the past it was the the common neo
which was this diy project it's like we
have this manual on github you have to
3d print some parts order a board
um
and it's like solder a connector to your
car you lost all stock system
capabilities
but that's uh luckily
no longer the case
then we shipped the eon with the giraffe
which had some nice switches
but even as an open as a comma employee
i could never remember what all the
switches did i always had to look it up
so it's not great for usability
and then that was fixed with the comma 2
and the car harness and
this turned out to be the future and
this is still used for the comma 3.
um
i'm also going to show a bit of the ui
progress we made i think this uh
very nicely shows how much openpipe has
progressed the software i think the ui
quality really nicely shows that
the state of the
self-driving code as well so this is the
original ui with the nice hacker font
this is what a something in a movie
would look like but
uh them started to become nicer and
nicer and this is all the react native
stuff it's turned out to be a mistake in
the end
and now we have this beautiful qt ui
which looks really slick
um to develop openpilot we also had to
develop quite a bit of tools
and libraries uh which i'll go over
briefly
so we developed cabana which is used to
reverse engineer the car
uh rob also talked about this a little
bit which produced opendbc which is this
big github repository with all the
reverse engineered signals
um we also added open file support to
quadjugar recently uh which is this very
smooth nice pulling library so you can
pull all the the signals of all the open
pipe modules and how they're
communicating with each other it also
parses out all the data from the from
the canvas so you can put those together
um yeah and you can also do live
streaming so if you're testing something
in the car and you can see it live for
tuning um this is so much better than
all the one-off uh jupiter notebook
scripts we use the riot and it's so much
faster to debug stuff with this
um
also added support for carla which is a
great way for new users to experience
open pilot
where they can try out open file without
a supported car
um i mean carla is not the most
realistic simulator but i i use it some
from time to time to see if like if i'm
writing a new feature just do some
sanity checks make sure i didn't mess up
a sign or anything it's not steering
left when it's supposed to go right
um we also made explorer
which is a nice way to view all your
drives or your dashcam footage but i'll
talk more about that later
here we um overall we made quite a bit
of progress i went from a proof of
concept
and to well over 3 500 weekly active
users
we went from a 3d printer case to an
injection molded case that's like a real
product product
we built some nice developer tools in
the process
and we also built some very nice
libraries so we try to keep the
number of dependencies low
but they also need to be resource
efficient so we wrote message queue so
we used to use zero mq which is nice
socket library but i used quite a bit of
cpu so we wrote our own library which
uses shared memory
research team read leica to do gps
processing and we developed open dbc in
the in the process
um i also want to talk briefly about my
timer comma
i'm
i've had a great time at comma so far
just i was looking for an internship and
then i uh saw the program i got sent a
programming challenge which i thought
was really cool way to hire at the time
uh so it kept uh tipped away it's a
chance for a weekend i feel like well
even if i don't get the internship at
least i had fun for a weekend
and i think that's the
the attitude that gets you into comma uh
i did uh well enough to uh to get an
internship which is a great start for my
time at comma
i made some great road trips in the u.s
with my comma devices it's really fun
uh we spent some days in the field as
well
this time we're testing av we're making
sure that all the all the forwarding of
the av still worked uh so went out with
ricardo and the deep and we uh printed
out this uh this bw golf uh stuck some
aluminum foil to the back taped it to
some boxes
um and then we rented this piece of
empty track
and then we just tried to drive into it
was this game of chicken with the boxes
and as you can see in the bottom right
it didn't always go successfully
um i also uh learned how to hack cars at
comma
so this is the time we uh
i guess we wanted to show the flex-ray
wasn't so insurmountable as people
thought
um so
the plan was to rent an audi a4 so rob
and i went up to la to pick up the the
a4
and um the person who rented this to us
really uh
he said it had all the driver assistance
features we needed but it didn't so we
had to give it back immediately and then
we went to mcdonald's and we started
looking for other audis with flex ray
but the only thing we could find with
the driver assistance features was this
absurd q8 uh so we picked it up in
compton
um and then we then went back to uh to
san diego for the hackathon
and we immediately filled it with wire
started hacking away
um and then after two very long days we
uh we finally got it to steer so it was
uh very nice to see that was possible
i also showed how absurd the use of
x-ray is in these cars uh i know some
some manager probably decided that they
need a flex rate uh so they put in this
this whole factory stuff and then they
stand sent the same exact cam messages
as on any vw golf but then they send it
on this super expensive bus
and so not sure why they did this
this is uh the combat 3 this was back in
san francisco
uh just
we
we decided we wanted to do rtk gps where
this is where you build like a base
station and you could do very accurate
gps i was a complete waste of time but
uh we had a lot of fun building uh the
comet through the combat three um which
i guess is the predecessor of the of the
chroma 3. um so we put this uh big gps
antenna on the roof got some two by
fours
um attached it to the outside of the
house and i had some cables running
through the bathroom
so sometimes when you're taking a shower
like the floor got wet and then the gps
antenna went down
so that's i guess that's the startup
vibe
um i want to talk about some
announcements uh i think love is already
spoiled by george with the navigation
we're going to start with connect
so we used to have explorer and the
mobile app connects but
yeah we decided it was not worth it to
deal with apple and the app store
anymore so we decided to just all
integrate this into this super nice web
app which is now live at connect.com.ai
uh it has all the features that from the
the phone app used to have and and way
more
um so yeah it's really cool you can see
your battery filtered you can take
snapshots and with the commentary you
can see your live location and
previously it would just show the the
last the position of the last drive you
took but now if your car would get towed
you could actually see the car in real
time
and we have now this nice unified
experience between desktop and mobile
um so yeah no longer in the app store
it's a nice progressive web app which
you can add to your home screen and it
will always be up to date
and this changed to to connect was also
very important for the next feature for
navigation
uh because we needed a good way for
users to enter their destination to
manage their favorites
um and like typing a destination on the
device is not really a not a really a
nice user experience
um
so yeah so we have connect and then we
have navigation on the device uh which
is just for my turn navigation but then
integrated into the open pi experience
so you can go to connect you type in a
location so if you want to go to taco
bell so that's very nice reverse geo
coding we'll show you all the taco bells
in the area
and you can add favorites you can add
home and work locations which will then
show up on your device like this so if
you're just starting up your device you
click home and i will just go there
you can also use the connect to set up a
destination um so how does so you type
in your destination it will preview the
route and then when you click navigate
it will actually go through athena
um so all the devices
on the common network have a websocket
connection open to our server um and
then if you're subscribed to prime uh
you can use this to uh to send the
location over to your device and this is
this is really smooth like within a
second that the map pops open with your
red loaded
it's really smooth experience
this is all based on
mostly map books and other open source
stuff
so the real thing is
i think it's busy based on valhalla
uh and then we use the the macbook's
driving api which is built on valhalla
with them with some traffic uh
information sprinkles on top a lot of
macbooks users send their real-time
location to macbooks so they have all
this real-time traffic information which
is really nice for us to use um
and then we render it on top of some
very sharp vector tiles and they have
this nice opengl library uh to render
these so it's it's very smooth
and yeah which looks really nice if you
just get this term by turn navigation
you've even got lane uh lane info if
that's available so in this case we'll
tell you to be in the leftmost line
uh and it will also tell you the traffic
so we know how much uh how long a rad
normally takes and if it takes longer
than that we can see for each segment
if that's the case and we can we can
show that as well
um
[Music]
but then the big question of course is
yeah so
uh what the future will look like so
it's important that you have comma prime
uh this pays for all the all the tiles
and all the writing requests we do and
pays for all the infrastructure uh so
yeah sign up when you get your comma
three just sign up for the trial
immediately
and enjoy this for a couple months
and see it just experience the
navigation experience
and then the question is like how are we
going to build this out to
navigate on openpod so however already
talked about desire which is this way to
signal to the layout to the model that
you want to make a lane change or keep
left and keep right
and of course this is going to be the
first step to see
if navigation tells you to keep left
what will happen if we tell the model to
do that
um but then we're also gonna
this is why it's very important that
navigation is an on-device experience
we can render a nice view of the map and
the routes that's specifically meant for
the model and the model can take
diagnose like a fourth camera
and then actually can make decisions
based on that and i think if we all put
that together uh train this with all the
data that's coming back from the
chemistry so i think
it's to feel like a magical experience
so yeah that was my presentation um i
hope you guys all saw what the nav looks
like in its current state and i think
once you try it out for the first time
it really feels like a
magical experience
um and i think i've also shown
how far we've come with open file how
how we've come from version 0.1 to
version
seven
and i think this just shows how much
more is possible and how good hopefully
it's going to be in the future
yeah that was uh that was my talk
you